at this moment
10 years ago the earthquake struck the
most powerful in japanese history
it was only the first blow in a triple
disaster that would take more than 18
000
lives today the emperor and the prime
minister
remembered so did all of japan
my heart aches when i turn my thoughts
to those who have struggled with various
hardships
with drastic changes of their living
conditions
including those who have lost close ones
such as family members or friends
and those who have lost their homes or
jobs and have been separated from the
people of their communities
a decade gone but only a moment ago for
those remembering the ones they lost
40 minutes after the earthquake the
tsunami thundering in
hit the shore it engulfed entire towns
for thousands there was no way out
i was forced to leave my hometown due to
the nuclear radiation
and it was listed as one of the
evacuation instruction zones
it was forbidden to enter before 2017
but even after the restriction was
lifted
the land around my house was so
radioactive that we had to tear it down
last september
now i've lost my home and the dwelling
has become a total wasteland
the third looming disaster soon became
clear
the fukushima nuclear plant had been
flooded too
over the next few days there were three
nuclear meltdowns it was the worst
accident since chernobyl
massive amounts of radiation were
released and more than 150
000 residents were evacuated
the plant remains out of service today
but this is an ongoing disaster
a cleanup operation that will take years
the spent fuel rods of the reactors are
still being removed and taken to storage
fukushima prompted a nationwide loss of
faith in nuclear power
one that endures to this day
after experiencing march 11 in tokyo and
knowing fukushima's situation
i came to the conclusion that nuclear
power plants are absolutely not needed
this is my strong belief and it hasn't
changed even after 10 years
that's why i came here it is a dilemma
for japan
which needs nuclear energy to meet its
renewable climate goals
the more immediate concern though is the
delayed 2020 tokyo olympics
they had been billed as the
reconstruction games foreign spectators
will not be allowed though a japanese
news agency has reported
the olympic torture relay will start in
two weeks
even in a pandemic and amid the enduring
pain of what happened
10 years ago it will also bring some
light
tom cheshire sky news beijing